elles étaient une trentaine une
trentaine de mères à manifester le
week-end dernier devant la place courbet
à trappes
pourquoi ce rassemblement elle souhaite
faire entendre leur voix face à la
violence qui se manifeste à trappes pour
aider les enfants d'avoir la santé et
une longue vie parce que tant pis bas il
se contrôle pas il peut se blesser et la
tempête des handicapés où il peut mourir
alors pour ça j'ai dit non on doit ou
les mamans de se mettre ensemble de dire
stop
maintenant je comprends je t'en veux
nous les mamans que vous avez la paix
cette manifestation fait suite à des
échauffourées ayant eu lieu devant la
mosquée de trappes il ya en moi un homme
avait été poignardé dans le dos une
violence qui rappelle la ferme où ça un
jeune collégien de 14 ans mort après
avoir pris une balle perdue des affaires
que le maire de trappes trou
inacceptables inacceptables au plan au
plan humain des événements violents qui
ont eu lieu il ya une quinzaine de jours
un deux soirs deux soirs consécutifs où
des des personnes ont été blessées et
blessé grièvement et donc aurait dit qu
on était passé de rossa de l'action
criminelle et que ça ce n'est pas
tolérable et que le fait que les mamans
un certain nombre de mamans et souhaité
exprimer leur désaccord avec cette
violence est était un élément
extrêmement positif un rassemblement
soutenue par l'acteur omar sy
originaire de la ville
[Applaudissements]